[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight the story of american
decline is the story of an incompetent
ruling class you'll hear many
self-serving explanations for but the
truth is it's that simple the people in
charge inherited an industrial
superpower with unchallenged military
dominance in a little more than a
generation they squandered all of it in
exchange for short-term profits bigger
vacation homes cheaper household help
they wrecked what they did not build
they outsource entire sectors of our
economy to China they imported a surf
class to drive down wages and they
crippled the middle class while doing it
they went up trillions in unpayable debt
they turned the finest universities in
the world into a joke they watch from
their decadent little bubbles of
affluence as families faith and public
decency died in this country and they
laughed because they didn't care how
people this awful wound up in charge of
a nation as great as ours is a question
historians will have to answer and they
will some day but at this point it's
clear the population has grown tired of
it
Donald Trump's election is one clear
sign of that the rise of Bernie Sanders
is another the ruling class in other
words is losing its grip on power and
they can feel it they could smell it it
terrifies them their first response was
denial it always is they were treated
into fantasy why can't we to select Joe
Biden and make it 2009 again that didn't
work and when it didn't they reverted to
their governing instinct which is
authoritarianism they stopped trying to
convince the public of anything and
instead decided to scare them fearful
people are easier to control you saw it
on the front page of their newspaper
this morning the New York Times
lawmakers are warning that Russia is
meddling to reelect Trump read the
headline inside the story there was
nothing no evidence no detail not even a
coherent set of accusations but it was
enough to alert the morons on cable news
that was time to do their job which is
now in all ways to run interference for
the people in charge now remember as you
watch the following clip that most of
the people on television have no idea
what they're saying even as they're
saying it they're just reading the
scripts that were written for them by
some 23 year old Women's Studies major
from Wesleyan someone
even less than they do so as you watch
try not to judge them too harshly it's
official
Russia has endorsed the re-election of
President Donald Trump who is trying
desperately right now to keep that
matter secret if the Russians are
attacking our election processes and
they're doing so to benefit Donald Trump
I think frankly the president welcomes
it he wants it so as bad as it is that
the Russians are back at it trying to
help Trump get reelected it's far worse
that the President of the United States
is he's trying to cover it up the
president is a Russian operative that
sounds like the description of a bad
Hollywood screenplay but it is real and
it is Vladimir Putin's greatest
achievement this is one of those
shocking news days if you retain the
capacity to be shocked in the Trump era
by the Trump regime which might be
better labeled the Trump Putin regime
the President of the United States has
colluded with Vladimir Putin to steal an
election no not the last one though that
one but the next one to be afraid says
Don Lemon be very afraid yet the public
doesn't seem especially afraid maybe
they've heard it before somewhere
their lack of panic is deeply
distressing to the Democratic Party
which is counting on another Red Scare
sometime between now and November so
Brian Williams trustee Brian Williams
stepped in to scold America for not
being more terrified we begin tonight
with sad word that funeral services are
pending this evening after the death of
outrage earlier today outrage officially
died of exhaustion though buoyed at the
very end by the one bright spot the
realization that his close relative
apathy survives and is thriving got that
screw you America you ought to be
falling for it a second time how dare
you you can see the frustration on their
faces on the other hand you think they
might take the time to come up with a
new hoax occasionally why can't they
invent Argentine sappers once in a while
or saboteurs from Malawi something new
and interesting but no like a robot
vacuum cleaner stuck carving
circles under a chair they're gonna keep
doing this same thing over and over and
over until the batteries run out and now
they're trying and I'm burning now you
might ask the question and some people
have would they want Trump over Bernie
Sanders Sanders of course a Democratic
Socialist has you know more
ideologically in tune with the old
Russia anyway and a member of course the
Russians did to favor Bernie Sanders in
the primary in 2016 over Hillary Clinton
weighed Bernie Sanders he's a Putin
stooge - we thought he was a Brezhnev
stooge whatever he's colluding with the
Russians he's got it because he's not
with the program just this afternoon The
Washington Post reported that quote
Bernie Sanders was briefed by US
officials Intel officials that Russia's
trying to help his presidential campaign
and quote now that happened weeks ago he
learned about a weeks ago but the
Sanders campaign ever leaked the story
now on the eve of the Nevada caucuses
someone in the so-called intelligence
community did leaked it just as they
repeatedly leaked selective information
in the first Russia hoax in an effort of
course to derail Donald Trump whose
policies they disagreed with you see
what's going on here yes you do our
democratic system is in fact under
attack that much is true but it's not
the Russians who are attacking it it's
not even the Chinese it's being attacked
by our own ruling class they're
undermining democracy because they have
no choice if they left it up to voters
to decide where to go next
they'd be out of a job tomorrow because
they've been terrible stewards of this
country some of them would be in jail so
they've got to subvert our system their
livelihoods depend on it